le 21 février le 28 février et le 7 mars
à chacune de ses entrées il y aura donc
le protocole que j'indique maintenant à
l'école primaire nous allons passer du
niveau 3 au niveau 2 ceci signifie que
certain nombre de règles du quotidien
vont évoluer positivement pour nos
enfants et je m'en réjouis en premier
lieu ça signifie qu'il n'y aura plus le
port du masque en extérieur en deuxième
que ça signifie que les brassages
resteront limitées mais non plus par
classe mais par niveau c'est important
et puis en troisième mieux ça signifie
aussi que les activités physiques
d'éducation physique donc ce peuvent se
passeront désormais en intérieur sans
masques sauf les sports de contact mais
donc c'est là aussi quelque chose qui va
améliorer le quotidien de nos élèves ce
sont des allégements donc conséquents et
encore une fois je m'en réjouis parce
que ça permet de rejoindre les règles
que nous avions pour le second degré qui
était resté au niveau 2 et qui le
restera mais et qui a eu évidemment
moins de perturbations au cours du mois
de janvier
notamment parce que nos élèves étant
plus vaccinée dans le second degré nous
avions pu nous permettre de rester à ce
niveau 2 donc un retour au niveau 2 pour
l'école primaire par ailleurs et
toujours conformément à l'avis du haut
conseil de santé publique nous faisons
évoluer aussi la doctrine de test
celle-ci donc fait que à partir du 28
février et de manière à la aussi
cohérente avec ce que ce qui se passe en
population générale on passe d'un
système à trolls de troy tests que nous
avons connue au mois de janvier un
système qui sera désormais de un test ce
test est un autotest qui se fera à j 2
et donc qui permettra là aussi beaucoup
plus de souplesse et puis j'ajoute à
cela que dès le 21 février
l'attestation sur l'honneur ne sera plus
exigé sera donc dans un système de de
confiance là aussi conformément à l'avis
du haut conseil et ce système va alléger
à la fois la vie des parents d'élèves et
l'avis des professeurs mais je crois que
maintenant l'habitude est prise de ces
auto test et nous savons que c'est plus
efficace à j 2 après parfois des
périodes d'incubation que l'on a quand
on n'a été qu'à contacter